und jetzt höflich die ausgabenanteile
den worten vorsitzende der cdu csu
fraktion ralf springob
so jetzt geht es also los mit der
zweiten dritten lesung zur änderung des
bevölkerungsschutz gesetzes egal wie man
zur pandemie steht ich glaube man kann
eins sagen dass alle kolleginnen und
kollegen letzten 13 monate mit dieser
pandemie verbracht haben mit
einzelhändlern mit gastronomen mit
familien die verzweifelt waren weil sie
ihre kinder nicht mehr zur schule
schicken konnten und mit ganz ganz
vielen anderen die von der pandemie
betroffen worden sind aber ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht
mich bringt das manchmal um den schlaf
aber wenn es mich um den schlaf bringt
wenn ich nachts wach wäldern denke ich
nicht an einzelhändler oder an
gastronomen sondern ich denke an die
menschen die krank geworden sind ich
denke an die menschen die ich dir und
ich bin dem bundestags bundespräsidenten
sehr sehr dankbar dafür dass er diesen
menschen ein gesicht gegeben hat letzten
sonntag und ich
auch den medien sehr sehr dankbar dass
sie mit vielen sehr berührenden
geschichten dass auch unterstützt haben
und dass sie mal gezeigt haben wie es
ist wenn man unter longo wird leidet
welche einschränkungen das mit sich
bringt dass man enkelkinder interviewt
hat die ihre großeltern verloren haben
ja und auch alte menschen sind wertvoll
und das ist wertvoll das leben und das
ist verlust das ist leere
das ist trauer und bei jungen menschen
gilt das natürlich auch so und deswegen
meine damen und herren wir diskutieren
hier sehr viel über das grundgesetz ist
auch richtig so dass überhaupt nichts zu
kritisieren aber das grundgesetz hat
auch den artikel 2 absatz 2 da steht
drin jeder hat das recht auf leben und
körperliche unversehrtheit
es ist unsere aufgabe es ist unsere
aufgabe als abgeordnete des höchsten
verfassungsorgans dieses leben zu
schützen leben und gesundheit zu
schützen und das ist mein anspruch an
politik warum ich in die politik
gegangen bin ich weiß nicht wie es
lieben und leben und gesundheit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
gefährdet und das hat auch sich nur der
professor marx von den intensivmediziner
angesagt sondern viele viele andere die
gesagt haben ihr müsst jetzt handeln wir
sind in einer situation wo nicht nur die
intensiv medizin überlastet ist wohl das
gesamte gesundheitssystem überlastet ist
wir sind in einer situation wo zu viele
menschen krank werden und wo zu viele
menschen sterben und deswegen ist es
notwendig dass wir hier und heute
handeln und ich sage ganz bewusst wir
weil wir als deutscher bundestag gefragt
sind an diesen rednerpult haben dutzende
von rednerinnen und rednern gestanden
die gesagt haben der deutsche bundestag
muss die entscheidung treffen nicht die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
der bundestagspräsident hat es uns ins
gebetbuch geschrieben
verfassungsrechtler haben es gesagt ich
glaube wir waren immer korrekt in der
vergangenheit
jetzt ist die zeit das der deutsche
bundestag entscheiden aber wer immer
sagt die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
kann sich ja nicht einigen und die tag
der auch zu lange dann müssen wir sagen
hier sind in der lage uns zu einigen wir
sind in der lage auch kompromisse
hinzubekommen
und wir haben als unions fraktion
zusammen mit unserem koalitionspartner
dieses gesetz im laufe des verfahrens
noch mal geändert um brücken zu bauen um
brücken zu bauen für alle diejenigen die
kritisch sind aber über diese brücken
muss man jetzt auch hinüber gehen und
über diese brücken übergehen heißt
kompromisse zu schließen ich sage ganz
ehrlich wenn ich das gesetz hätte
alleine schließen können dann wäre es
härter und schärfer geworden aber das
gebietet der respekt auch vor der
mehrheitsbildung dass man da an der
einen oder anderen stelle diesen
kompromiss macht und kompromisse sind
kein zeichen von schwäche sondern stärke
in der pluralen demokratie und ich kann
nur jeden aufrufen zu sagen
es fällt mir vielleicht schwer an der
einen oder anderen stelle zuzustimmen
aber dieses gesetz ist es insgesamt wert
dass es heute durch den deutschen
bundestag geht denn wenn wir heute keine
mehrheit kriegen dann wird es kein
gesetz geben wenn es kein gesetz geben
wird dann gibt es keine notstands
regelungen um wenn es keine notstands
regelung geben wird dann werden menschen
krank werden und dann werden menschen
sterben und dass die aet war diesen satz
zwei damen und herren das zeigt die
fratze die diese partei hier in diesem
deutschen bundestag hat
und jetzt wird gesagt und jetzt wird
gesagt wird gesagt ja das schränkt den
föderalismus nein dieses gesetz ist vom
hohen respekt vor dem föderalismus
geprägt weil wir nämlich weil wir
nämlich erst einsteigen nicht bei 10 das
waren die inzidenz zahlen letzten
sommers als die heimlichen normalität
hatten nicht bei 35 was wir selber ins
infektionsschutzgesetz reingeschrieben
habe nicht als 50 was wir als notfall in
diese reflektion schutzgesetz
reingeschrieben habe sondern bei 102 wir
den ländern zutrauen dass sie das unter
100 auch hinkriegen dass sie regional
differenziert mit experimentierklausel
mit test und vielen vielen anderen
sachen klarkommen aber 100 ist auch ganz
unabhängig von den anderen indikatoren
so hoch dass eingegriffen werden muss
und dass wir eine bundesweite regelung
war auch meine damen und herren und die
schaffen wir heute liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und dann ist letzte woche weiß nicht ob
wahrheitswidrig oder versehentlich
behauptet worden dass dieses gesetz die
demokratie abschaffen
meine damen und herren nie war so viel
demokratie in der pandemie bekämpfung
wie jetzt
es ist so dass dieser deutsche bundestag
als höchstes verfassungsorgan ein
eindeutig entscheidet wenn er passiert
dann muss diese folge da seid da gibt es
keinen spielraum für die bundesregierung
das ist demokratie und der zweite punkt
ist selbst bei der rechtsverordnung die
die bundesregierung erlassen kann ist es
so dass wir noch mal nachgebessert haben
und gesagt haben und diese
rechtsverordnung bedarf der zustimmung
des höchsten deutschen verfassungsorgane
des deutschen bundestages und wer da
sagt dass demokratie geschleift wird der
frage ich mich hat er dieses gesetz
gelesen hat das nicht gelesen oder
verbreitete er hier ungehalten
um auf zu hetzen und populistisch
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen kann sich
über die eine oder andere maßnahme
durchaus streiten das ist auch gemacht
und das ist überhaupt keine frage jetzt
wurde in der letzten debatte in der
ersten lesung gesagt ja aber da muss man
sich jetzt raus impfung hat will ich
muss man sich raus impfen und wir werden
auch besser entspannen wird gleich in
seiner rede sagen aber das wird für die
nächsten wochen nicht reichen da
brauchen wir zusätzliche maßnahmen und
dann wird gesagt ja das kriegen wir mit
individuellen regionalen test konzepten
hin testen ist gut testen ist wichtig
testen ist richtig dass es überhaupt
keine frage
aber hier ist kein land bekannt was sich
aus hohen inzidenz zahlen runter
getestet hat am anfang stand immer der
lock down und dann wurde getestet und
regional gearbeitet
und deswegen brauchen wir diese
maßnahmen die wir jetzt haben und jetzt
ist es so das ist auch in der debatte
gefallen auch eben von herrn kurth ich
glaube er hat es nicht so gemeint da ist
gesagt worden
aber weil das und das in diesem gesetz
schlimm ist oder in der ersten lesung
ist gesagt worden weil die
bundesregierung ich halte das für falsch
nicht genügend impfstoff beigebracht hat
bei nicht genügend getestet worden ist
können wir jetzt diesem gesetz nicht
zustimmen weil die arbeitgeber nicht
entsprechend belastet sind können wir
jetzt diesen gesetzlich zu stimmen herr
korte wen wollen sie bestrafen wir ihn
wollen sie bestrafen wollen sie alle
bestrafen weil sie dieses gesetz nicht
vollumfänglich dann entsprechend
zustimmen können es geht nicht jetzt um
politische vorteile sondern es geht um
die gesundheit von den menschen in
diesem land und dass leute und leicht
freundliche
und die sagen 1 dieses gesetz ist
notwendig dieses gesetz muss hier im
deutschen bundestag verabschiedet werden
und nirgendwo anders dieses gesetz
respektiert die den föderalismus dieses
gesetz berücksichtigt dass wir mehr
impfen und dass wir mehr testen und
deswegen ist es begrenzt auf den 30 06
und dieses gesetz ist nach unserer
festen auffassung nach feste auffassung
des bundesinnenministers der
bundesministerium für justiz und
verbraucherschutz auf verfassungsgemäß
und deswegen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich habe eine herzliche bitte
ich habe wirklich eine herzliche bitte
wir werden und das wird jetzt sparen
gleich noch erläutern mit einer
unglaublichen dynamik im bereich impfen
in diesem sommer aus dieser pandemie
rauskommen und viel viel normalität
wieder zurückbekommen aber bis dahin ist
es unsere entscheidung hier im deutschen
bundestag die viele menschen erkranken
und vielleicht auch sterben und deswegen
deswegen kann ich sie nur um eins bitten
dieses gesetz ist ein gesetz fürs leben
dieses gesetz beruht auf artikel 2
absatz 2 des grundgesetzes und bitte
stimmen sie diesem gesetz zu stimmen sie
für das leben und haben dann auch die
entsprechende entscheidung auch wenn es
schwer fällt in der zweiten und dritten
lesung ich habe wirklich die ganz ganz
ganz herzliche bitte schützen sie leben
stimmen sie zu herzlichen dank brinkhaus
der fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
fraktion hier zum auftakt dieser zweiten
dritten lesung ja ein gesetz fürs leben
er hat sich auf dem angeschlossen was
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel gestern
bzw
letzte woche bereits bei der ersten
lesung gesagt hat da hatte sie ja
gesprochen wer sind wir denn dass wir
diesen hilferuf der intensivmediziner
überhören können
und jetzt hören wir was die auf die dazu
sagt alexander gauland der
fraktionsvorsitzende
ich bilde mir nicht ein die mehrheit für
dieses gesetz in diesem hause mit einer
rede noch zu verändern
und wenn ich da bis jetzt zweifel gehabt
hat hat die rede von herrn brinkhaus mir
deutlich gemacht dass die regierenden
nicht bereit sind irgendetwas einzusehen
zu festgezurrt trinkaus ist der wille
der regierenden mit untauglichen mitteln
die pandemie zu bekämpfen als das
einreden der opposition die ja nicht nur
von uns kommen ihren angriff auf die
freiheitsrechte den föderalismus wie den
gesunden menschenverstand noch stoppen
können
wenn der kollege brinker aus wie am
freitag geschehen gegenargumente des
kollegen lindner als politische
profilierung auf kosten von kranken und
toten bezeichnet ist jede sachliche
auseinandersetzung zu ende und das
moralisieren an die stelle von politik
getreten herr brinker aus merken sie
sich das bitte mal
sie stecken in ihren schützengräben fest
und werfen der opposition die struck
zion vor
aber diese diskussion geht von jenen aus
die in der impfstoff beschaffung versagt
haben
die ihr multilaterales europäer
multilaterale europa ideologie wichtiger
nehmen als den lebensschutz der vielen
die auf dem ait der bundeskanzlerin
vertraut haben schaden von diesem volke
abzuwenden frau bundeskanzlerin
statt impfstoff zu beschaffen wo immer
es welchen zu beschaffen gibt ganz
gleich welche geopolitischen
verwerfungen damit verbunden sind damit
hausärzte betriebsärzte und wir auch
immer dazu in der lage ist patienten zu
impfen
wollen sie das erste mal in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik die
freiheitsrechte des grundgesetzes
einschränken
nein das ist kein quatsch das ist
tatsache
und statt so viel wie möglich bewegung
an frischer luft zu ermöglichen wie es
in monologen und arioso forscher
empfehlen wird aufgrund einer inzidenz
die jederzeit manipulierbar ist das
öffentliche leben still gestellt was sie
zu beginn versäumt haben sollen nun
beschränkungen zu lasten der menschen
richten was das an kollateralschäden für
die gesellschaft bedeutet hat meine
kollegin weiter bei der einbringung
dieses gesetzes dargestellt mir bleibt
nur warnen darauf hinzuweisen dass hier
ein experiment ausprobiert wird von dem
manche hoffen man könne es bei anderen
gelegenheiten wiederholen wenn die
bundeskanzlerin davon spricht dass mit
dem virus nicht zu verhandeln ist so
werden wir bald hören dass auch mit dem
klima nicht zu verhandeln ist und die
einschränkungen von heute auch für die
schöne neue welt von morgen tauben meine
damen und herren der publizist heribert
prantl weiß gott kein freund der afg
sagt er fürchte dass die aktuellen
grundrechts einschränkungen als
blaupause verwendet werden
für das nächste virus für den nächsten
katastrophenfall
denn wo man nicht verhandeln kann gibt
es nur eine einzige sprache der
entschlossenheit
schließlich geht es immer ums ganze um
die weltgesundheit das weltklima eben
das überleben der menschheit
dann kann man endlich aufhören
gesellschaftliche ziele und die
politischen wege dorthin in den
parlamenten in der öffentlichkeit zu
diskutieren und stattdessen gleich zur
tat schreiten was sie mit dem gesetz
nach thun im grunde lassen sich für
jeden bereich für fast jeden bereich der
politik ins tänzen quoten oder zielwerte
festlegen deren erreichen entschlossene
und vor allem unverhandelbare maßnahmen
erforderlich machen
wir werden uns bei der klimapolitik
wiedersehen an die stelle der
langwierigen politischen willensbildung
im kleinen dritte objektive
notwendigkeit entschlossenen handelns im
großen und die altmodische trennung von
regierung und opposition verwandelt sich
in den scharfen gegensatz von
vernünftigen und querulanten aber die
die da draußen protestieren sind nicht
alles querulant
sie können nicht das halbe volk zu peru
land machen teile damen und herren aber
genau dass die einschränkung unserer
grundrechte für wie auch immer
begründete ihre politische ziele wollten
wir nach den erfahrungen zweier
diktaturen in der deutschen geschichte
nie mehr zulassen
meine damen und herren die grundrechte
sind abwehr rechte des bürgers gegen den
staat
der staat ist immer übergriffig das ist
seine natur
deswegen wurden die grundrechte
geschaffen die grundrechte stehen nicht
noch nicht
unser pandemie und klima vorbehalt ich
hoffe das bleibt auch so wenn ich ihre
argumentation sehe weiß ich dass es
nicht so bleiben wird
deshalb ist dieses gesetz ein tabu co
auch wenn sie versucht haben die
giftzähne am ende ein wenig
abzuschleifen und den bundestag nicht
ganz außen vor zu lassen
meine damen und herren die belastung und
überlastung des gesundheitssystems wäre
ein richtiger maßstab politischen
handelns als die nur vorgebliche
objektive instanz allerdings für die
frage in welcher ordnung wir leben
wollen haupt er so wenig wie die
magische 100 oder 165 oder 200 ihres
gesetzes
deswegen lehnen wir das gesetz ab und
erbringt aus das ist eine politische
auseinandersetzung mit dem wort von der
fratze haben sie sich selber dekoriert
mit solche debatten geführt werden
sie führen hat das mit politik nichts
mehr zu tun
es ist nur noch moral knabberei ich
bedanke mich alexander gauland war dass
der fraktionsvorsitzende der afg
fraktion ja er hat die da draußen
angesprochen es sind demonstrationen
angemeldet gegen das
infektionsschutzgesetz hier rund um das
berliner regierungsviertel das ist sehr
weiträumig abgesperrt tausende
polizisten sind auch aus anderen
bundesländern zur unterstützung hierher
gekommen es ist unter anderem einer
demonstration am brandenburger tor
angemeldet getönt wir den vizekanzler
olaf scholz hier in der aussprache
herr präsident meine damen und herren
zunächst mal möchte ich eine richtige
gute nachricht des heutigen tages hier
besprechen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat heute
den weg frei gemacht für die
ratifizierung des europäischen
wiederaufbau programms ein wichtiger
schritt in der bekämpfung der pandemie
in ganz europa und gemeinsam
und er zeigt dass wir noch lange damit
zu tun haben die pandemie zu bekämpfen
nicht nur wenn es um die
gesundheitlichen folgen geht nicht nur
wenn es um die risiken für das leben
vieler bürgerinnen und bürger geht
sondern eben auch wenn es um die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen der
pandemie gibt geht und ich sage an
dieser stelle noch einmal klar und
deutlich es ist richtig dass wir mit
enormen fiskalischen mitteln dazu
beitragen das leben in unserem land
arbeitsplätze und unternehmen zu retten
und dass wir es in europa gemeinsam tun
die lage ist unverändert ernst
und das will ich sagen weil man ja nicht
immer sicher ist auch alle das auch so
sehen
heute sind einige unterwegs auf den
straßen dieser stadt die sagen es wäre
nicht ernst es wäre fast nichts los doch
es etwa 80.000 bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes sind gestorben und darüber
kann man nicht hinweg reden und auch
nicht hinwegsehen
weil das es unfall die lage unverändert
ernst ist muss auch etwas getan werden
über das hinaus was wir bisher
unternommen und das was wir jetzt
brauchen ist klarheit und konsequenz was
ist wenn die inzidenz werte wenn die
infektionszahlen zu sehr steigen und wir
sagen wenn sie über 100 gehen dann muss
etwas getan werden und das gehört zu
klarheit und konsequenz dazu über in
deutschland und auch immer und in jedem
fall letztendlich sind das die regeln
über die wir jetzt hier entscheiden und
ich glaube dass sie zur verständlichkeit
für viele bürgerinnen und bürger
beitragen werden und auch dazu dass
viele mitmachen denn das viele
durcheinander hat ja auch dazu
beigetragen dass man sich nicht mehr so
sicher ist was zu tun ist und ob das
wirklich richtig ist ich glaube mit
diesem gesetz werden wir noch einmal
eine neue große unterstützung bekommen
für all die maßnahmen die jetzt
erforderlich sind weil sie gemeinsam
vollzogen sind und eine angelegenheit
der großen gemeinschaft unserer bürgern
und bürger sind das müssen wir erreichen
und das werden wir mit diesem gesetz
meine damen und herren was dazugehört
ist dass wir uns klar machen dass die
lage für viele nicht einfach ist und das
hat ja auch mit dem ernst dieser lage zu
tun den kindern zum beispiel die ganz
lange zeit die schulen nicht gesehen
haben denen manchmal sehr engen
wohnungen mit sehr großen familien leben
sie haben verdient dass wir uns um sie
kümmern sie haben verdient dass wir
deshalb auch sagen kind schulen werden
zuletzt geschlossen als erste wieder
geöffnet trotz all dieser strengen
regeln aber sie haben auch verdient dass
wir in eine chance für die zukunft geben
dass aufholjagd ist eine antwort darauf
was notwendig ist
und vergessen wir nicht unverändert sind
viele alleine und einsam auch das ist ja
mit den verschiedenen beschränkungen und
regeln verbunden und auch die haben
verdient dass wir schnell durch diese
sache kommen und dass wir deshalb mit
klarheit und konsequenz handeln und
klarheit und konsequenz sind auch
wichtig für die unternehmen die um ihre
existenz bangen
die sorge haben dass sie nicht
durchhalten bis zum ende der pandemie
und die jetzt von uns die botschaft
haben wollen wir haben ein kurs den wir
konsequent verfolgen und der dazu
beitragen wird dass neben dem
finanziellen mitteln wie auch ein ende
der pandemie zustande bringen und das
ist die aufgabe die mit diesem gesetz
verbunden ist
und denken wir auch an die pflegekräfte
um die ärztin und ärzte all diejenigen
die in den krankenhäusern in
altenpflegeeinrichtungen jeden tag
arbeiten und dafür sorge tragen dass die
gesundheit so viele bürgerinnen und
bürger geschützt wird sie können fast
nicht mehr sie schuften jeden tag und
auch sie haben verdient dass wir mit
klarheit und konsequenz handeln weil es
die voraussetzung dafür ist dass auch
dort einmal all diese anstrengung ein
ende finden weil wir es geschafft haben
werden das ist mit diesem gesetz
verbunden
meine damen und herren die entscheidung
die wir jetzt hier treffen fallen
natürlich zusammen mit einer ganzen
reihe von weiteren maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen zb dass die vielen neuen und
zusätzlichen möglichkeiten zu testen
jetzt auch ergriffen werden dass wir
sicherstellen dass tatsächlich überall
testzentren in deutschland eingerichtet
worden sind und jetzt verfügbar sind
dass wir sicherstellen dass in den
schulen zweimal die woche getestet wird
dass wir sicherstellen dass das in der
unternehmen der fall des wie das mit der
arbeitsschutzverordnung geschehen wird
dass wir dafür sorgen dass das
home-office deutlicher durchgesetzt wird
auch durch eine neue starke regelung im
infektionsschutzgesetz alles das gehört
dazu und sicher zu stellen und dass die
hierdurch punkt und natürlich auch das
gehört dazu dass wir die hoffnung in den
blick nehmen die mit dem impfen
verbunden ist
denn tatsächlich machen ja die impfung
große fortschritte
der bundesgesundheitsminister wird es
ausführlicher darstellen da bin ich
sicher aber ich will ausdrücklich sagen
dass jetzt über 16 millionen bürgern und
bürger erstmalig geimpft sind das über
20 prozent der bevölkerung geimpft sind
das ist ein fortschritt jähriger wegen
seiner geschwindigkeit auch sichtbar
werden dass dass wir eine chance haben
im sommer vielleicht einmal wieder in
einem biergarten zu sitzen und das ist
die perspektive die wir gemeinsam mit
den strengen regeln
verfolgen muss es geht nicht um einen
dauerzustand es geht darum die pandemie
zu überwinden und darum sind die regeln
auch richtig
was wir darüber hinaus tun ist dass wir
natürlich sehr sorgfältig abwägen dass
wir überlegen was zu tun ist wenn die
lage sich verändert und deshalb ist es
richtig dass in diesem gesetz eine
verordnungsermächtigung enthalten ist
über die wir hier in diesem haus viel
diskutieren werden die abgeordneten
müssen zustimmen und das finde ich
richtig so über die wir diskutieren
werden mit den ländern in deutschland
was wir nämlich zu tun haben und was wir
tun wollen wenn es geimpfte gibt die die
möglichkeit haben bestimmte
erleichterungen auch zu nutzen
denn das ist die verordnungsermächtigung
zuallererst das wär festlegung treffen
was geschieht mit geimpften was
geschieht mit denen die chinesen sind
was es mit den ihnen die tests haben und
dass wir das in einem guten richtigen
nachvollziehbar vernünftig diskutierten
rahmen stellen und dass wir den bald
festlegen
auch diese erleichterung möglichkeit
gehört zu den strengen gesetz dazu sie
ist ebenfalls erforderlich und notwendig
und ein letzter satz was wir hier machen
und worüber wir heute beraten und wo was
sie heute hoffentlich beschließen werden
verehrte abgeordneten neun abgeordnete
dass es nicht frei gegriffen das baut
auf sehr sorgfältigen verabredung
zwischen bund und ländern die
unterschiedlich umgesetzt worden sind
ihr aber doch einen gemeinsamen rahmen
hatten und dass wir uns darauf beziehen
dass wir das hier in eine strikte
regelung umsetzen das gehört zur
klarheit und konsequenz auch dazu und
das ist das gebot der stunde
schönen dank
olaf scholz war dass
bundesfinanzminister aber auch
vizekanzler hier eine aussprache und die
bundeskanzlerin gehört natürlich auch
dieser debatte zu letzte woche bei der
ersten lesung da hatten sie das wort
ergriffen
jetzt werden wir aus der bundesregierung
übrigens auch noch ihren sparen und
später hören hier in der aussprache
hören aber jetzt mal erst zu christine
aschenberg-dugnus für die fdp ja wir
sind uns hier alle einig dass kaká
corona virus stellt weiterhin eine große
gefahr für die gesundheit aller
bürgerinnen und bürger da und es ist
unsere oberste aufgabe das virus zu
bekämpfen
und ja wir als bundestag
fdp-bundestagsfraktion halten
bundeseinheitliche regelungen für
wichtig sonst hätten wir ja auch nicht
schon vor wochen einen stufenplan
vorgelegt der genau das vorsieht und den
haben sie herr brinkhaus mit ihrer
fraktion damals abgelegt auch die aktive
zustimmung des bundestages weil
rechtsverordnung ist selbstverständlich
zu begrüßen denn eine parlamentarische
beteiligung meine damen und herren ist
immer auch eine qualitätskontrolle bei
dieser qualitätskontrolle und das hat
die anhörung gezeigt ist ihr gesetz aber
durch gefallen meine damen und herren
ihr gesetzesentwurf hat erhebliche
handwerkliche mängel denn alle maßnahmen
zur eindämmung des virus müssen auch
geeignet sein und herr brinkhaus
erstaunlicherweise habe ich zur
geeignetheit dieser mittel überhaupt
nichts von ihnen gehört ich wundere mich
darüber auch nicht denn die vorgesehenen
ausgangssperren sind eben keine
geeigneten maßnahmen
es gibt keine wissenschaftlichen evidenz
die belegt dass ausgangssperren die
verbreitung des virus verhindern allein
darauf zu hoffen dass es etwas bringt
reicht eben nicht aus um einen so schwer
den grundrechtseingriff zu rechtfertigen
meine damen und herren wir benötigen
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse und keine
behauptungen das haben gerichte so
entschieden das sagt der überwiegende
teil der verfassungsrechtler und wir als
bundestagsfraktion sagen dass auch und
meine damen und herren es existieren ja
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse die
erosion forscher haben es dargelegt
ausgangssperren bringen zur eindämmung
desinfektions geschehens rein gar nichts
sie schränkt nur in unzulässiger weise
die grundrechte ein und treiben die
menschen weiter in den privaten bereich
und das kann doch gerade nicht unser
interesse sein meine damen und herren
der fokus muss auf solchen maßnahmen
liegen die tatsächlich zu einer
eindämmung des virus führen das ist
natürlich impfen impfen impfen testen
bessere aufklärung über kontakt
vermeidung und aha regeln im privaten
bereich
nächster punkt die sieben tage incidents
es ist als alleiniger maßstab völlig
ungeeignet das infektionsgeschehen
abzubilden
auch in unserem stufenplan den ich schon
erwähnt habe haben wir bereits diese
faktoren vorgeschlagen und genauso jetzt
in unserem änderungsantrag eine
gewichtete sieben tage incidents danach
soll mit einbezogen werden der anteil
der positiv befunde an zahl der
geimpften personen belastung der
intensivstation und so weiter und so
weiter eine anfrage an das
bundesministerium hat bestätigt die
anzahl positiver pcr test ergebnisse
allein zeigt nicht die schwere der
pandemie an
warum haben sie das sind dann nicht in
ihr gesetz geschrieben alle damen und
herren nächste änderungsantrag von uns
modellprojekte die bundes notbremse darf
doch nicht dazu führen dass die
wichtigen modellprojekte wie in
thüringen zum beispiel einfach
abgebrochen werden
das widerspricht jeglichen es meine
damen und herren
meine damen und herren wir als fdp
bundestagsfraktion haben von anfang an
für konstruktive gespräche bereit
gestanden auch unter zeitdruck sechs
ändere
anträge ein entschließungsantrag haben
wir ihnen vorgelegt sie haben alle
unsere argumente jetzt einfach beiseite
geschoben es ist grob fahrlässig hier
ein verfassungsrechtlich fragwürdigen
gesetzesänderung auf den weg bringen zu
wollen
ihre gescheiterte oster ruhe hat doch
gezeigt wie viel vertrauen dabei
verloren gehen kann ein solcher
vertrauensverlust darf sich nicht
wiederholen meine damen und herren
im ergebnis werden wir das gesetz
ablehnen und gestatten sie mir bitte
noch den letzten hinweis sollten sie
unsere änderungsanträge ablehnen und die
ausgangssperre kommen dann werden wir
eine verfassungsbeschwerde in karlsruhe
auf den weg bringen herzlichen dank ja
das auch die liberalen jetzt schon
mehrfach angekündigte und tatsächlich
wird er aber erstmal über ganz diverse
änderungen noch abgestimmt aber man kann
sich denken dass die
regierungsfraktionen mit ihrer mehrheit
dagegen stimmen werden und dass dieser
weg den die fdp da einschlagen will dann
wahrscheinlich auch so kommen wird
auch die linke hat übrigens heute
mehrere änderungsanträge noch vorgelegt
wir hören jetzt die fraktionsvorsitzende
am ihrer mohammed ali es geht um leben
und tod
das infektionsgeschehen das muss
dringend eingedämmt werden aber es macht
die bundesregierung
sie taumelt von einem murks in den
nächsten und auch jetzt legen sie uns
wieder ein stück werk vor das die großen
probleme nicht lösen wird und das ist
unverantwortlich
im vergleich zur letzten woche haben sie
im bevölkerungsschutz gesetz einiges
ungeschickt die maßnahmen sind es
befristet der persilschein für die
bundesregierung weitere maßnahmen zu
erlassen ist entfallen gut aber die
wahrheit ist dass sich hier erst auch
unseren massiven druck hin bewegt haben
und das erleben wir übrigens nicht zum
ersten mal in dieser pandemie dass sie
versuchen grundrechts einschränkungen
einschränkungen praktisch im vorbeigehen
ohne befristung einzuführen und die
befugnisse der regierung
die auszuweiten das ist und bleibt
untragbar ich kann ihnen versichern
die linke wird das niemals akzeptiert
wir wir leben ihr gesetz weiterhin ab
und ich sage ihnen auch warum sie wollen
ausgangssperren pauschalen sident von
100 verhängen obwohl die wirksamkeit
dieser maßnahme hoch umstritten ist aber
der eingriff in die grundrechte massiv
was jedoch wissenschaftlich sehr gut
belegt ist
das ist der hohe anteil an ansteckungen
am arbeitsplatz trotzdem nehmen sie nach
wie vor die arbeitgeber nicht richtig in
die pflicht unglaublich home office soll
kommen aber sie kontrollieren es nicht
richtig ja test sollen kommen aber nicht
verpflichtend nur ein angebot für ein
bis zwei tests pro woche das ist doch
zahnlos also die zeit dass man immer
noch bitte bitte den unternehmern sagt
die muss doch endlich vorbei sein wir
brauchen endlich schutz für alle
menschen an allen arbeitsplätzen und
auch auf dem weg zur arbeit in den
schulen
schon lange schlagen schülervertreter
eltern lehrer alarm und was tun sie
obwohl sie ab einer inzidenz von 100
ausgangssperren verhängen wollen sollen
die kinder bis zu einer incident von 165
in die schule gehen also ich kann alle
eltern verstehen wir nur noch mit dem
kopf schütteln können woher haben sie
eigentlich diese zahlen ein würfel wie
die auf und es ist auch irrsinn dass die
kinderkiste runde der inzidenz in voller
klassenstärke unterrichtet werden sollen
die klassenstärken wir müssen reduziert
werden das ist der schlüssel
und genauso kann man aber den kopf
schütteln über ihre pläne
dass kinder bis 14 jahren im freien
sport treiben dürfen ab 15 aber nicht
mehr
ich meine das doch absurd brauchen
kinder ab 15 weniger bewegung und
ausgleich wieder wieder denken sie eben
nicht an die jungen menschen die eben
keine großen gärten und spielzimmer
haben aber das ist leider nichts neues
diese bundesregierung die ignoriert
konsequent die tatsache dass die
gefahren von kogit 19 eben nicht für
alle menschen gleich sind
das ansteckungsrisiko und das risiko
eines schweren verlaufs ist für menschen
mit niedrigem einkommen
nachgewiesenermaßen deutlich höher
wegen der ämter wohnverhältnisse weil
man nicht im home office arbeiten kann
weil man in vollen bussen und bahn zur
arbeit fahren muss um bahn zur arbeit
fahren muss und kommen auf eine
schlechtere gesundheitsversorgung haben
und sich gesunde ernährung nicht leisten
können das ist die wahrheit die
verkäuferin beliefern und die erzieherin
es ist doch wirklich eine schande das
sieht die menschen die sie hier wieder
und wieder beklatscht und gelobt haben
weil sie die wahren stützen unserer
gesellschaft in dieser pandemie sind
dass sie die immer noch nicht genügend
schützen sondern weiterhin im stich
lassen unsere position als linke ist
klar wir brauchen infektionsschutz und
er muss solidarisch sein
niemand darf auf der strecke bleiben und
das heißt wirksamer schutz an allen
arbeitsplätzen und auf dem weg zur
arbeit viel mehr tests und luftfilter
für die schulen bessere unterstützung
von lehrern und eltern auch im
homescreen und natürlich müssen endlich
wie sozialen härten dieser pandemie
vernünftig abgefedert wird
es geht nicht dass angst und
verzweiflung bei immer mehr menschen um
sich greifen deshalb drängen wir seit
über einem jahr darauf endlich
ausreichende und unbürokratische hilfen
für kleine unternehmen zur verfügung zu
stellen inklusive eines unternehmens für
solo selbstständige künstlerinnen und
künstler
wir brauchen unbedingt eine verlängerung
der auszahlung von arbeitslosengeld 1
einen monatlichen zuschlag für menschen
in grundsicherung und eine angemessene
gehaltserhöhung für alle pflegerinnen
und pfleger und alle anderen die
pandemie im gesundheitswesen im
einzelhandel und in der logistik doppelt
und dreifach belastet werden ja und
ich werde nicht aufhören das hier zu
sagen wohnungs mit kündigungen und
stromsperren auf grund finanzieller nöte
die gehören verboten kolleginnen
kollegen aber ich befürchte kolleginnen
und kollegen von der bundesregierung all
das stößt bei ihnen wieder auf taube
ohren
und sie werden unsere anträge die wir
heute einbringen wieder nicht annehmen
dabei wäre das so dringend nötig denn es
ist vollkommen klar es ist so nicht
weitergehen kann weder in dieser
pandemie noch danach
wir brauchen ein gesundheitswesen in den
nicht der profit sondern das wohl der
patienten im mittelpunkt steht
wir brauchen schulen mit ausreichend
personal und mitteln um allen kindern
eine bessere bildung zu garantieren
wir brauchen einen sozialstaat der die
menschen zusammenführt und das land fit
für die zukunft macht aber sie können
sich darauf verlassen dass wir als linke
dafür weiter entschlossen kämpfen
das weiß dann allerdings einiges über
den jetzt hier vorliegenden gesetz
hinaus was am ihrer mohammed ali
die fraktionsvorsitzende der linke hier
noch alle alles in die debatte
eingebracht hat zumindest zum ende wie
gesagt die linke ja auch mit diversen
änderungsanträgen über die dann im
anschluss abgestimmt werden wird auch
die grünen haben etwas vorgelegt und wir
hören jetzt maria klein schmeink ihr
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der bündnisgrünen herr präsident
sehr geehrte damen und herren die lage
ist weiterhin ernst
die intensivstationen sind voll ärztin
und pflegekräfte am absoluten limit
immer mehr junge menschen erleiden
schwere verläufe deshalb wir als grüne
fraktion haben bereits bei der
einbringung klargemacht wir brauchen ein
sozusagen ein schnell wirksam
wellenbrecher und der ist zwingend
erforderlich und brinkhaus er stolz ich
habe eben sehr gut zugehört
es ist in der tat so wir brauchen
klarheit wir brauchen konsequenz aber
sie tragen die verantwortung dafür dass
sie allzu lange zugeschaut haben dass
wir zu spät zu zögerlich zu
widersprüchlich gehandelt haben und die
konsequenz dessen was wir jetzt erleben
ist resultat dieses nicht handeln und
ganz besonders bezeichnet ist das sieht
auch jetzt wieder den bereich der
arbeitswelt der so wichtig ist für
kontakt beschränkungen ausgelassen haben
das im übrigen hat auch die fdp wieder
in ausdrücklicher weise getan und es
seien sehr froh dass es endlich dazu
kommt dass der bund die verantwortung
wahrnimmt
das finden wir richtig das fordern wir
schon sehr lange wir haben deshalb auch
durchaus gerungen gestern in der
fraktion denn ein weiter so darf es
nicht geben dieses fahren auf sicht war
verantwortungslos und ist weiterhin
verantwortungslos wenn wir nicht jetzt
klar und konsequent handeln denn es
läuft sehr sehr viele menschen an der
handlungsfähigkeit unseres staates
zweifel gleich holen müssen wir nach
diesem herausfordernden
beratungsverfahren sagen wir können am
ende diesem infektionsschutzgesetz
dieser notbremse so nicht zustimmen
denn sie handeln zu spät zu unwirksam
und sie handeln
weiterhin so dass wir nicht das tun was
wir jetzt tun müssen wir anerkennen dass
es einmal im verlauf der beratung und
verhandlung durchaus verbesserungen
gegeben hat für die arbeitswelt beim
home office für die schule auch dabei
der präsenzpflicht und auch bei dem
bereich der ausgangs beschränkt aber
insgesamt reichen diese maßnahmen nicht
aus um tatsächlich eine trendumkehr hin
zu bekommen und genau die würden wir
brauchen zusätzlich ist dieses gesetz
handwerklich schlecht gemacht es ist in
sich inkonsequent und dem konsistent wie
sehen wir haben eine 35er instanzen
hunderter von incidents 965 er incidents
und 150 er ins ident das versteht kein
mensch und das ist auch wissenschaftlich
nicht hergeleitet deshalb diese
notbremse bleibt zu halbherzig zu wenig
wirksam zu wenig konsistent zu wenig
verhältnismäßig und deshalb können wir
an dieser stelle nicht zustimmen zu
stimmen sondern wir erwarten eine
weitere weitere gesetzgebung damit wir
hinkommen zu echten maßnahmen die
wirksam sind
das sagt maria klein schmeink für die
fraktion fraktionsvorsitzende ja und
jetzt hören wir wie schon angekündigt
einen weiteren vertreter der
bundesregierung hier sehen wir ihn schon
auf der regierungsbank jens spahn den
bundesgesundheitsminister
jetzt hat der bundesgesundheitsminister
hier entspannen
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen des corona virus hat
deutschland verändert im großen wie im
kleinen
diese pandemie und der kampf gegen
dieses virus ist prägt unseren alltag
es verursacht leid herten und kosten für
den einzelnen und für die gesellschaft
und ja seit über einem jahr ist es
notwendig unter abwägung auch unter
unwägbarkeiten tiefgreifende
entscheidungen zu treffen und heute sind
weitere notwendig über jede einzelne
dieser entscheidung muss es in einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft debatten
geben und es muss ein abwägen geben so
wie wir das in den beratungen der
letzten tage jedenfalls die die an den
beratungen teilgenommen haben gemacht
hat manche fragen nun was ist anders als
vor einem jahr hat sich nichts geändert
noch mal die gleichen maßnahmen in der
ersten in der zweiten welle
doch viel hat sich geändert die medizin
die wissenschaft jeder einzelne von uns
weiß heute mehr über dieses virus wie es
sich über trägt was es im körper
anrichtet wir wissen auch besser wir uns
schützen können wir haben unseren
instrumentenkasten beständig erweitert
zwei beispiele
wir haben inzwischen beachtliche test
kapazitäten aufgebaut in den laboren
aber vor allem auch ein schnelltest seit
der bund den kostenlosen bürger test
übernimmt und eingeführt hat sind über
15.000 test stellen im ganzen land
entstanden und es werden jeden tag mehr
und auch die impfkampagne hat sich enorm
beschleunigt wir haben neue tages
rekorde gesehen und werden bald weitere
sehen allein gestern wurden über 500
35.000 menschen geimpft
mittlerweile ist jeder fünfte deutsche
geimpft anfang mai wird es jeder vierte
sein in wenigen wochen jeder dritte herr
bundesminister stellen sich zwischen den
bulligen ich finde die debatte ist schon
lebhaft genug das geht jetzt ohne
helgoland werden gerade über impfstoff
beschaffung geredet und ich finde es gut
wenn sie grundsätzlich über
multilateralismus hier beim impfen
aber noch wichtiger finde ich ist wenn
sie in dieser phase für das impfen
werben würden sie persönlich tun das mit
beispiel bundesparteitag hat vor dem
impfen in dieser pandemie gewarnt sie
können hier noch so viel über
multilaterale fragen und grundsätzlich
keiten in der pandemie reden wenn sie
selbst nicht für das impfen werden
werden sie nicht für den weg raus aus
dieser pandemie und das ist das problem
mit ihrer partei dass sie am ende nicht
genau wissen was sie wollen
und dieser von aber impfen und testen
alleine reicht nicht um die dritte welle
zu brechen wir können das virus nicht
weg testen wir können auch gegen eine
welle nicht an impfen
das ist keinem land gelungen übrigens
auch nicht israel oder dem vereinigten
königreich wir müssen also erst diese
dritte welle brechen
und dazu gibt es ein mittel ein
bewährtes erprobtes ein ebenso banales
wie wirksames mittel
das reduzieren von kontakten und damit
von infektionen so schwer es fällt so
leid wir es sind kontakte reduzieren
hilft denn nur wenn wir anderen begegnen
hat das virus eine chance sich zu
verbreiten
die lage ist das virus lässt sich
übrigens auch nicht weg schreien und
wegleugnen das hilft auch wenn die lage
ist ernst sehr ernst
dafür reicht ein kurzer blick auf die
härteste währung in dieser pandemie ein
blick auf die intensivstation die
tagesaktuell sind und die sich auch
nicht irgendwie relativieren dass wir
zählen wieder 5019 sind
intensivpatienten tendenz weiter
steigend bei sinkendem alter der
patienten
wir dürfen nicht vergessen jeder dritte
kurve patient in der klinik nicht nur
auf den intensivstationen jeder dritte
kurve 19 patient in den kliniken stirbt
die lage ist in vielen krankenhäusern
weiter dramatisch patienten müssen
verlegt werden andere behandlungen
verschoben
seit unserer ersten debatte hier im
bundestag war ein ziel jedenfalls für
die mehrheit dieses hauses und für die
bundesregierung immer klar wir wollen
eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems vermeiden
eine überlastung übrigens die viele
unserer nachbarländer schmerzhaft erlebt
haben und ja sie haben wir das
grundgesetz geredet ralph brinkhaus hat
darauf hingewiesen in dem grundgesetz
gibt es auch schutzrechte und
verantwortung für den staat und für uns
alle und die gesundheitliche
unversehrtheit gehört dazu wenn sie
schon dass grundsätze und gesetz und die
der frage zum maßstab machen auch in
ihren debatten dann sollten sie auch die
richtigen schlussfolgerungen daraus
ziehen mitten in einer pandemie die so
viel leid verursacht am vergangenen
sonntag habe ich die intensivstation in
köln merheim besucht was professor pds
und sein team dort jeden tag leisten
übermenschliche belastungsgrenzen hinweg
das darf uns als gesellschaft nicht
selbstverständlich sein und wir können
ihn nur dankeschön sagen für das was im
leben etwas tun und wir können ihnen
dabei nur zu sagen dass wir auch ihre
eindringlichen warnungen ernst nehmen
es gibt eine korrelation zu der zahl der
intensivbetten die zahl der
neuinfektionen da gibt es eine
korrelation
einige versuchen immer diese beiden
zahlen voneinander zu trennen aber sie
hängen miteinander zusammen dass eine
folgt logisch dem anderen und wir haben
das doch in den letzten monaten gesehen
nicht nur in deutschland auf der ganzen
welt und dessen verstehe ich die logik
nicht dass einige immer warten wollen
bis die intensivstation überfüllt sind
bevor sie maßnahmen machen wenn wir leid
vermeiden können sollten wir es
vermeiden rechtzeitig und infektionen
erst gar nicht entstehen lassen und
genau dem dient dieses gesetz eine
notbremse per bundesgesetz notbremse
heißt übrigens auch vorher sollte man
das bremsen schon beginnen durch
regionale und lokale maßnahmen
es geht um drei lebensbereiche die
aktuell die infektion ausmachen der
betrieblichen alltag schon angesprochen
worden warum office mehr test
verpflichtungen weniger mobilität der
alltag in schule und kita
auch dort mit klaren vorgaben für
regelmäßige tests für wechsel unterricht
und betreuung und übrigens bei den 6 bis
20 jährigen sehen wir gerade sehr sehr
viele infektionen und der bereich der
privaten kontakte das sind die drei
bereiche wo wir gerade viele auch
ausbrüche sehen zwei drittel aller
ausbrüche in deutschland finden im
moment im privaten bereich statt
und deswegen sind kontakt und ausgangs
beschränkungen notwendig es ist schwer
es fällt doch keinem von uns leicht
diese maßnahme die eine sehr stark
einschränkende maßnahme zu machen aber
mit vorübergehenden maximal bis zum 30
juni 2021 begrenzt
einschränkungen wollen wir diese frage
in dieser phase der pandemie adressieren
diese einschränkung die schwer fallen
die hart sind sind angesichts der lage
angemessen verhältnismäßig und sie sind
im übrigen auch geeignet frau kollegin
wie wir nahezu allen anderen ländern
europas gesehen haben deswegen der
präsident die kolleginnen kollegen diese
bundesland bremse ist das ergebnis eines
demokratischen prozesses mit intensiven
beratungen und entsprechenden
anpassungen und sie ist übrigens auch
der wunsch der großen mehrheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger die sich
einheitliche verlässliche regeln
wünschen denen sie vertrauen können und
nun werden wir auch in diesen schweren
hoffentlich letzten teil des pandemie
marathons dann gut überstehen wenn wir
zusammenstehen und die notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreifen test gestütztes
öffnen und vor allem das impfen geben
uns die notwendige perspektive nach der
zu recht viele fragen aber er ist
braucht es als brücke einbrechen dieser
welle dem dient dieses gesetz und daher
bitte ich um ihre zustimmung jetzt waren
der bundesgesundheitsminister und er hat
auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass
natürlich auch unter einer incidents von
100 maßnahmen getroffen werden können
dann vor allem von den ländern weil die
bundes notbremse die gilt ja bei einer
incidents von 100 über sie über drei
tage und dann natürlich in dem
jeweiligen landkreis beispielsweise für
strenge kontakt beschränkungen
nächtliche ausgangssperre
wer zu tun und selten waren aufgaben
komplexer herausforderungen größer als
in dieser zeit
nun ist fdp vor einer woche vorgeworfen
worden wir würden das von ihnen damals
werks richtige eilverfahren bremsen und
doch zeigt sich dass sie das ganze
wochenende noch zeit gebraucht haben um
den gesetzentwurf noch einmal zu
überarbeiten
es gab beratungsbedarf in der koalition
es gab einen nachbesserungsbedarf am
gesetz nicht die fdp war schuld dass wir
uns diese zeit genommen habe und es hat
sich gelohnt weil der damen und herren
denn immerhin ist jetzt gesetzentwurf
besser geworden das zeigt sich es ist
gut ein ordentliches
gesetzgebungsverfahren zu durchlaufen
nichtsdestoweniger sieht die fdp
weiterhin verbesserungsbedarf
das als ein aspekt dass im gesetz
weiterhin ausnahmen für geimpfte und
genesene fehlen
es gibt zahlreiche studien die uns sagen
dass namentlich durch geimpfte praktisch
keine gefahr der ansteckung mehr für
andere menschen ausgehen
nun ist das infektionsschutz recht
gefahrenabwehr recht
das heißt also wenn von einer person
keine gefahr mehr für andere ausgeht
dann gibt es auch keine rechtliche und
auch keine moralische rechtfertigung
mehr in die grundrechts ausübung dieser
person einzugreifen und deswegen müssen
wir diese ausnahmen ins gesetz
hineinschreiben darunter ein zweiter
aspekt ist wir nehmen die
gesundheitsgefahren durch corona sehr
sehr ernst aber wir nehmen auch die
nebenfolgen der panini bekämpfung
politik sehr ernst vor allem der
einzelhandel braucht perspektiven wie
zum beispiel durch intelligente test
strategien weiter existieren kann
denn wenn uns das nicht gelingt bayer
damen und herren dann werden wir unsere
innenstädte bald nicht mehr
wiedererkennen können
und der punkt ja auch mir persönlich am
wichtigsten ist
wir dürfen die bildungschancen unserer
kinder nicht aufs spiel setzen
die inzidenz von 165 165 166 einhalb für
schulschließungen ist doch nicht das
resultat wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
es ist das ergebnis eines politischen
deals meine damen und herren
wenden sie sich doch nur mit gleicher
energie die köpfe heiß redeten wie man
schulschließungen verhindern kann
durch technische maßnahmen durch eine
intelligente strategie auch für schulen
oder wenn sie denn wirklich mal sein
muss einen wirklich guten in distanz
unterricht für alle kinder meiner und
herren wenn sie das so durchziehen dann
wird in manchen landkreisen deutschlands
in diesem schuljahr zu gar kein
schuleröffnung mehr kommen
präsident ich komme zum schluss ja die
gesundheitsgefahren sind sehr sehr real
aber wenn wir die wirtschaftlichen
sozialen und pädagogischen nebenfolgen
der anime bekämpfung nicht genauso
ernsthaft angehen wie die panne wie
bekämpfung selbst dann werden wir nicht
in das gleiche land zurückkehren aus dem
wir gekommen sind
stephan thomae war das für die
fdp-fraktionen der noch einmal
vorbehalte der liberalen natürlich
formuliert hat jetzt eine gleich rolf
mützenich der fraktionsvorsitzende der
spd fraktionen auch aus den
regierungsfraktionen gab es in der
letzten woche an diesem jahr von ihnen
selbst vorgelegten gesetzentwurf noch
große kritik und auch deswegen ist ja
zahlreich noch mal verändert worden auch
hinzugefügt damen und herren unsere
fraktion hatte beim
infektionsschutzgesetz von anfang an das
ziel den gesundheitsschutz vor allem für
die arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
zu stärken und für mehr einheitlichkeit
und nachvollziehbarkeit bei den
maßnahmen zu sorgen das haben wir
geschafft
darauf haben wir uns konzentriert und
von nichts und von niemanden haben wir
uns in diesen tagen davon ablenken dass
meine damen und herren
und deswegen ist es gut dass wir das
home-office gestärkt haben
das home office dient eben mit dazu zu
diesen kontakt beschränkungen zu kommen
aber es schafft eben auch den
gesundheitsschutz für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
ich habe es sehr bedauert dass
eigentlich die möglichkeiten die die
arbeitgeber gehabt hätten nämlich home
office in einer größeren zahl zur
verfügung zu stellen nicht freiwillig
gemacht haben sie haben es zu
verantworten dass wir das jetzt in
dieses gesetz haben bringen müssen es
ist noch luft nach oben und ich bitte
die arbeitgeber dies jetzt auch endlich
zu nutzen und zum anderen
das testangebot jetzt zweimal die woche
für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer die in die betriebe kommen
müssen ist wichtig und ich frage mich
schon warum wird das immer noch von dem
einen oder anderen in den
unternehmensverbänden hinterfragt es ist
doch nicht nur eben ein schutz für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
sondern für das unternehmen es kann dann
weiter wirtschaften und diese konsequenz
haben wir jetzt auch in dieses gesetz
getragen
meine damen und herren ich bin froh und
der bundesfinanzminister hat es in der
vergangenen woche zum nachtragshaushalt
angekündigt wir wollen zwei milliarden
euro in die hand nehmen um 1 auf hohe
paket auf den weg zu bringen weil kinder
und jugendliche brauchen unsere
unterstützung wir brauchen auch wenn wir
medizinisch gesundheitspolitisch die
pandemie eingegrenzt haben hilfen für
diejenigen die auf der strecke bleiben
deswegen ist außerschulische hilfe ist
die einbeziehung der kinder und
jugendhilfe sind freizeitangebote so
wichtig umgeben das wieder gutzumachen
was wir eben auch kindern und
jugendlichen angetan haben ja und wenn
ich das hier vielleicht mal in der
realität ihnen auch etwas nahe bringen
kann
was ist die situation ein kölner ein
einliter einer kölner grundschule wusste
vor einiger zeit zu berichten dass eben
kinder sich doch nicht testen lassen und
er ist dem nachgegangen und warum haben
sich die kinder nicht testen lassen
naja weil die eltern eben nicht das
wollten weil sie dann angst um ihren
arbeitsplatz gehabt hätten wenn sie in
quarantäne hätten gehen müssen und das
ist die realität und deswegen wenden wir
uns genau denjenigen zu die so viel leid
auch ertragen müssen und ich bin dankbar
wenn das kabinett nächste woche diese
frage beschließen wird und meine damen
und herren wir bringen das
kinderkrankengeld noch mal zu einer
wesentlichen stärkung für die familien
die eben keine betreuung für ihre kinder
gewährleisten können
und insbesondere diese maßnahme ist
wichtig um finanzielle unterstützung zu
leiten und auf der anderen seite jahr
kollege tournee genau das ist jetzt auch
in diesem gesetz verankert der deutsche
bundestag wird sich eben wenn die
verordnung ansteht und wenn wir sicher
sind dass geimpfte nicht mehr das virus
übertragen wird sich der deutsche
bundestag eben mit dieser verordnung
befassen und das ist wichtig dass eine
große kompetenz die die
volksvertreterinnen und volksvertreter
hier einzubringen haben meine damen und
herren und zum zum schluss in dieser
frage wird auch ein neuer rechtsweg für
die bürgerinnen und bürger eingezogen in
diesem gesetz nämlich über eine
vorbeugende feststellungsklage können
die bürgerinnen und bürger eben auch
schon gegen maßnahmen die sie
unmittelbar betreffen vorgehen der
schaffen rechtssicherheit rechtsklarheit
und wir schaffen eine
nachvollziehbarkeit der maßnahmen meine
damen und herren die pandemie hat unsere
gesellschaft und jeden einzelnen von uns
geprägt und deswegen danke ich dank
meiner fraktionen den bundespräsidenten
dass er eine würdige eine angemessene
trauerfeier am vergangenen wochenende
hat veranstalten lassen es war
insbesondere nicht nur eine trauerfeier
für die toten nicht nur eine trauerfeier
für die genesenen und nicht nur eine
trauerfeier für die familienangehörigen
die eben auch noch mal abschied nehmen
konnten von der irren verstorbenen
sondern es war auch eine trauerfeier für
uns für die gesunden weil wir an
teilnehmen konnten an den leit an dem
schicksal was diese pandemie für dieses
land bedeutet was nicht durch gesetze
aus der welt gebracht werden kann und
deswegen muss ich sagen finde ich
unwürdig
wie sich einige hier in diesem tiefst
verstörenden augenblick verhalten
es ist nicht nur unanständig sondern es
ist unwürdig gegenüber den betroffenen
nun gegenüber den familien angehörigen
dass sie davon faseln dass die pandemie
herbei getestet wurde
gehen sie in die krankenhäuser reden sie
mit den familienangehörigen die ihre
angehörigen verloren haben reden sie mit
den pflegekräften die sich
aufopferungsvoll in dieser pandemie
dieser pandemie auch entgegenstemmen
sie haben die gefahr klein geredet in
diesem haus und sie haben sie schuldig
gemacht in der pandemie weil nämlich
dadurch auch menschen die situation auch
vernachlässigt haben und es ist
ungeheuerlich dass sie sich auf das
grundgesetz berufen verfassungsfeinde
haben sie schon einmal der verfassungs
bemächtigt und wir meine damen und
herren werden uns dem entgegen stemmen
vielen dank sportlich war das der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd fraktion
der die bundesregierung kann abgesehen
dass fortlaufend das sind gesetzt diese
bundes notbremse verankert ist die
bundesregierung kann in zukunft eigene
verordnungen erlassen
dies ist noch nicht konkretisiert das
könnten also zusätzliche maßnahmen rund
um corona ge oder verbote seien und sie
kann nämlich auch für geimpfte und
getestete damit mehr freiheiten
einräumen wie schnell oder wann diese
verordnung genau kommt dass es
allerdings offen
festrednerin jetzt erfüllt konnte für
die grünen verstorbenen und schwer
erkrankten der kuna pandemie gedacht
inzwischen sind allein in deutschland 80
tausend menschen gestorben jede einzelne
fehlt ihren familien fehlt ihren
freundinnen fehlt uns allen
es muss uns doch auftrag sein unserer
politischen verantwortung nachzukommen
und maßnahmen beschließen die geeignet
sind die infektionszahlen
schnell und wirksam zu senken wer der
pflege werden erzählen nicht nur im
gesundheitsausschuss zu hört der weiß
doch wie ernst die lage in unseren
krankenhäusern ist immer mehr junge
menschen liegen im krankenhaus und sie
kommen oft erst sehr spät fast wende
schon zu spät ist die nächste mutation
klopft an einfach so weiter ist
fahrlässig die bundeseinheitliche
warnung für die maßnahmen ist überfällig
dass haben wir grüne lange gefordert und
es ist gut dass sie heute kommt wie
konnten glücklicherweise in den
beratungen noch deutliche verbesserungen
verhandeln doch die koalition bleibt
trotz alledem auf halber strecke stehen
wir haben doch heute hier treffende
analyse gehört warum ziehen sie denn
nicht die wirksamen konsequenzen
wir brauchen mehr als eine halbherzige
notbremse ab 100 die erst greift wenn
der zug schon an die wand fährt wir
brauchen eine echte show punkt her
die dritte welle muss gebrochen werden
die infektionszahlen dauerhaft gesenkt
werden
nur so schaffen wir perspektive für
öffnungen für räumlich trennen zwischen
folge ja gern herr kollege frau kollegin
carport konto vielen dank dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen
ich muss sagen ich frage mich heute
jetzt schon in der ganzen debatte wie
eigentlich reden und handeln der grünen
zusammen passt
sie sprechen davon dass sie
verantwortung übernehmen wollen
frau casselman hat vorhin in der geo
debatte zurecht und leidenschaftlich
gesagt wir müssen heute entscheiden
und dringend handeln jetzt enthalten sie
sich ich frage sie frau kaputt kontor
ist enthaltung eine haltung heißt
verantwortung heißt verantwortung
übernehmen für die grünen enthaltung und
wenn es um so viel geht wie sie ja auch
deutlich machen warum sitzt ihre
kanzlerkandidatin der in der letzten
reihe und schweigt
beantwortung heißt hier etwas
angemessenes vorzulegen und das würde
bedeuten maßnahme die zielführend sind
die abgewogen sind die
verfassungsrechtlich sauber sind und die
geeignet sind diese instanzen wirklich
zu senken
wenn die uns hier ein gesetz vorlege was
einerseits nicht wirksam genug ist was
anderes als nicht konsequent genug ist
und auf der anderen seite höchst
umstrittene verfassungsrechtlich höchst
umstrittene ausgangssperren beinhaltet
dann können wir weder zustimmen noch
ablehnen und dann ist die haltung die
konsequente haltung
wir erkennen an was sie tun und wir
sehen was sie versäumen und dringend
nachbessern müssen und das bedeutet in
der konsequenz enthaltung
und nur so
nicht die insolvenzen senken würden nur
so würden wir eine perspektive für
öffnungen für kultur für begegnung
schaffen
gerade weil die menschen auf dem
zahnfleisch gehen weil die seelischen
erkrankungen zunehmen die menschen
wütend und wütend und müde sind dieses
neue wort mutant brauchen wir
konsequentere maßnahmen für eine echte
perspektive deutlich konsequenter als
das was sie heute vorlegen konsequenter
wäre im arbeitsbereich mehr
verantwortung zu übernehmen
verpflichtendes forums ist das auch
wirklich kontrollieren sonst fb2 masken
pflicht und verpflichtende schnelltests
und zwar mehrfach die woche stark für
konsequente schutzmaßnahmen am
arbeitsplatz für kinder für familien zu
sorgen
man kann sie aber die eben schon kurz
angesprochene verfassungsrechtlich
bedenkliche ausgangssperre
das schadet das schadet auch der
akzeptanz die maßnahmen müssen
verhältnismäßig sein sie müssen von der
bevölkerung nachvollzogen und dann auch
eingehalten werden können
es ist unser großes potenzial dass die
menschen wirklich mitmachen und das ist
nicht das was ihr gesetzt hier in gänze
ermöglicht nur perspektive schafft
akzeptanz und ja und das erkennen wir
ausdrücklich an mit unser
abstimmungsverhalten ja dieses gesetz
leistet einen beitrag
sonst würden wir uns ja auch sonst
würden wir ja auch ablehnen aber es
reicht eben nicht aus und enthält die
angesprochenen problematischen seiten
und das
in einer seriösen abwägung in einer
abwägung aller argumente die wir
vorhaben eine enthaltung und eins muss
klar sein die verhandlung komödien paket
mit entschlossenen maßnahmen brauchen
ihre zeit ist auch schon außen ich danke
ihnen jetzt so das motto von ndr vor wie
petri kokko petri ist eine von
mittlerweile acht fraktionslosen
abgeordneten im deutschen bundestag
sitzen die haben natürlich auch
rederecht dennoch etwas eingeschränkt in
diesem fall für frauke petry also zwei
minuten
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren die große koalition
möchte heute das vierte
infektionsschutzgesetz verabschieden von
dem sachverständigen mediziner und weite
teile der bürger unternehmer dringend
abraten
herr brinkhaus dies ist kein gesetz für
das leben
dies ist vor allem die fortsetzung einer
chaotischen regierungsführung seit über
einem jahr
und offenbar ohne perspektive das
politische vernunft wieder einzug hält
ich erinnere mich noch gut an das lob zu
recht für die vielen guten lokalen
lösungsansätze im vergangenen jahr und
zwar ganz ohne ausgangssperren ohne
masken pflicht und vor allem ganz ohne
weisungen aus berlin
dann zog mit dem ministerpräsidenten
konferenz der völlig
unwissenschaftlichen bezugnahme auf pcr
test oder berücksichtung tatsächliche
krankheitssymptome zentralismus und
alarmismus in die deutsche debatte ein
sie wollen nun suggerieren das
weitgehende einschränkungen der
grundrechte
beschäftigungsverbote und die
wissenschaftliche unsinnigen
flächendeckenden ausgangssperren bessere
resultate als ziel als entscheidungen
vor ort wo man sich kennt wenn ein
profit aus puren eine pflegeheim oder in
einem einzelnen wohnblock eines
einschlägigen wohngebietes ob mit oder
ohne schwere verläufe ob er geimpft oder
umkämpften eine ganze region oder stadt
statistisch zu roten zone werden lässt
und das leben lahm legt dann helfen ihre
gesetzesänderung überhaupt nicht sie
helfen nicht den erkrankten frau sie
nehmen über 99 prozent der betroffenen
bürger in mithaftung nein statt
zentralismus brauchen wir föderalismus
weniger kanzleramt weniger wasser und
mehr kommunale autonomie daten
verweigern sie sich frau bundeskanzlerin
die untauglichkeit ihrer pc
sie denn sonst so die beurteilung der
lage endlich anzuerkennen weil dann
angst und dramatik ihrer pandemie als
instrumente zur koordinierung der bürger
endlich als demokratie schädigend
unverantwortlich erkannt würden sie
bringt die polizei in und fertig
konflikte wenn sie beamte zwingen
spaziergänger spielen die kinder und
überhaupt alle freiheitsliebenden bürger
zu kontrollieren und zu verfolgen
nur weil die sich eher normales leben
leben wollen ganz zu schweigen von den
millionen tipps oder musikern die sich
schon länger mundtot gemacht haben
dieses gesetz ist das im paragrafen
gegossene misstrauen einer regierung die
nicht ein virus sondern die mündigen
leistungsträger dieses landes bekämpft
mit allen mitteln was für ein niedergang
eines ehemaligen freiheitlichen landes
im herzen europas
frauke petry wales als fraktionslose
abgeordnete hat sie ihr gesprochen und
jetzt hören wir für die cdu/csu-fraktion
die nächsten redner stephan stracke der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
ja und da kommen wir dann schon so
langsam zum abstimmungsprozedere nicht
nur über den gesetzentwurf wird ihr
abgestimmt sondern auch über ganz viel
zahlreiche änderungsanträge der
opposition alles dafür tun diese dritte
welle zu brechen umzukehren und deswegen
schaffen wir ab einem incidents wert von
100 ein einheitlich instrumentarium das
für alle in gleicher weise und gleich
konsequent greift damit erzielen wir
eine größere wirkung gegenüber
regionalen lösungen und darauf kommt es
jetzt an denn die lage ist sehr ernst
denn wir erleben längere
krankheitsverläufe wie erleben
krankheitsverläufe von vier jüngeren und
es sind die berufstätigen die gerade auf
der intensivstation liegen die kollegin
von storch würde ich eine zwischenfrage
stellen
nein danke meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wir brauchen die
intensivbetten natürlich für coop 19
patienten aber wir brauchen sie auch für
diejenigen die mit der herzinfarkt
aufgrund von unfällen aufgrund von
notfalls ob es in unserer krankenhäuser
kommt wir haben eine schutzpflicht
gegenüber leben und gesundheit gegenüber
den menschen und diese schutzpflicht
nehmen wir wahr mit diesem gesetz und
wir setzen auch schnelligkeit das
bedeutet dass wir mit diesem gesetz in
kraft setzen am freitag wenn bundestag
und bundesrat zustimmen das macht einen
unterschied ab samstag in den
landkreisen
wir setzen auf wirksamkeit all dieser
maßnahmen die wir tun den begreifen bei
den schulen an
wir greifen bei
den arbeitsstätten und den privaten
bereich anders sind die haupt
infektionsherde in diesem bereich und
wir setzen natürlich auch auf akzeptanz
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
für all diese maßnahmen braucht es die
notwendige akzeptanz und ich habe den
eindruck dass diese in der bevölkerung
wieder stärker wächst weil die lage
ernst ist und wir werben dafür wenn die
regeln nicht mehr in der breite
akzeptiert werden dann beginnen sie auch
an wirkung zu verlieren und deshalb
setzen wir beispielsweise auf die
bewährten lösungen einzelhandel für
click & collect und termin shopping mit
test und wir setzen auch bei den
ausgangs beschränkungen beispielsweise
darauf dass die erst ab 22 uhr
entsprechend eintreten das ist ausdruck
der lebensrealität das nehmen wir ernst
diese balance von schnelligkeit von
wirksamkeit und von akzeptanz ist bei
diesem gesetz gewahrt ich bitte um
zustimmung herzliches dankeschön
[Applaus]
nichts verrät nicht der kollege mario
mir hoch
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren folgt der wissenschaft hören
wir seit über einem jahr
aus sicht der regierung aber
offensichtlich nur der ihr genehmen denn
die andere hälfte der am freitag
gehörten sachverständigen sieht in
diesem gesetzentwurf ein so massives
problem dass zwei von ihnen sogar damit
rechnen dass das gesamte gesetz vom
verfassungsgericht kassiert wird der
brinkhaus ich möchte sie fragen welche
brücken haben sie denn gebaut die sie
vorhin angekündigt haben wieder gibt es
keine begründung warum der bund es
besser können soll als die länder
und obwohl es unmissverständliche
aussagen zum gefährdungspotenzial innen
und außen gibt wollen sie jetzt eine
testpflicht für einen zoobesuch oder für
sport im freien für die begleitperson
sie wollen sie nicht fürs einkaufen
nicht für das spazierengehen im park und
auch für die heutige sitzung hier im
saal der gut besucht es war keine tests
nicht erforderlich ich frage sie wo ist
das gefährdungspotenzial höher
gerade hier oder wenn die familie allein
im freigehege im zoo steht erklären sie
mir das bei den zahlreichen
einschränkungen von grundrechten haben
sie doch im entwurf bleibt das
grundrecht auf versammlungsfreiheit
vergessen also sagt fix mit einschränken
ebenso die unternehmerische freiheit
einfach abwürgen
wenn kinder und jugendärzte sagen
schulen sind nicht die hotspots ist ihre
reaktion zahl runter 165 gewürfelt der
bund der verwaltungsrichter fügt diesen
entwurf die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft befürchtet
keinen zusammenbruch obwohl die lage
schwierig ist keine frage sie wissen
dass alles diese stellungnahmen liegen
ihnen vor gibt es schwarz auf weiß
jetzt wollen sie tests mit ce
zertifizierung anerkennen das ist prima
das ministerium spannend war es dass man
beim material aus asien schnell mal eben
mit 20% ausschuss kalkulieren muss und
den hat er schon mal im echten leben
industrielle waren dort bezogen hat weiß
das nicht unbedingt überall ce
draufsteht auch drin ist was draufsteht
und jetzt nehmen sie ihre instanzen an
denen sie alles festmachen stellen dass
diesen unwägbarkeiten gegenüber und
fragen sich was das alles noch wert ist
ich sage es ganz deutlich wer heute für
dieses papier abstimmt den muss die hand
abfallen
geben sie ihr mandat beim rausgehen am
besten gleich ab denn sie wollen es ja
anscheinend nicht wahrnehmen und
enthalten ist heute auch feige die lage
ist ernst keine frage aber wir sind als
volksvertreter aufgerufen die verfassung
zu schützen und sie nicht entgegen
besseren wissens und trotz aller
fundierten warnung zu brechen vielen
dank
marion jedoch war das ein weiterer
fraktionsloser abgeordneter und jetzt
kommen wir zum letzten redner bevor
abgestimmt wird über das
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz heißt es ja
ganz formal was im wesentlichen aus
änderungen oder ergänzungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes besteht letzter
redner jan marco luczak für die
unionsfraktion präsident sehr verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind jetzt
am ende einer debatte wo viele argumente
hin und her gewogen wurden und es sind
wirklich auch schwierige fragen
politisch der schwierige phasen auch
verfassungsrechtlich schwierige fragen
deswegen ist es gut dass wir hier im
deutschen bundestag darüber diskutieren
aber ich glaube man darf trotz der
ganzen argumente nicht vergessen
weswegen wir diese bundeseinheitliche
notbremse am ende machen und dann möchte
ich schon noch mal zurück erinnern an
den letzten als letzte wochenende an den
letzten sonntag 80.000 menschen haben im
zuge der knapp an dem ihr leben von den
80.000 menschen und das ist nicht nur
irgendeine zahl dahinter stehen
schicksale dahinter stehen familien die
unsägliches leid erfahren mussten weil
sie manche noch nicht einmal abschied
nehmen konnten von den menschen die auf
den intensivstationen lagen und jetzt
nicht mehr unter uns sind familien sind
zerstört worden und ich finde
es war richtig dass wir ein solches
signal am letzten wochenende ausgesetzt
haben aber ich finde auch und ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht
ich bin nicht dafür in den deutschen
bundestag gewählt worden um signale
auszusenden sondern ich bin gewählt
worden um zu handeln und das machen wir
mit diesem gesetz liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
denn wir haben denn wir haben eine
verpflichtung politisch und auch
rechtlich dass wir den staatlichen
schutzauftrag nach punkt dass wir das
leben und die gesundheit der menschen
aktuell eher gewünscht würden sie noch
eine zwischenfrage zu lassen
nein vielen dank wir haben die argumente
ausgedacht wir haben einen schutzauftrag
dass wir das leben und die gesundheit
schützen und deswegen handle werde
deswegen sind wir entschlossen die
dritte welle zu brechen
und deswegen haben wir auch einen bunten
bausteine von instrumenten und die
ausgangs beschränkungen die jetzt von
allen oppositionsfraktionen zur
kritisiert worden sind ich weiß gar
nicht was sie für studien wiesen gucken
sich das doch mal an die
wissenschaftliche lage ist eindeutig
selbstverständlich bringen ausgangs
beschenken auch etwas bei der pandemie
bekämpfung und es ist ein baustein von
vielen und deswegen brauchen wir auch
diese ausgangssperren deswegen brauchen
wir diese beschränkung weil wir sagen
wir müssen alles tun damit das leben der
menschen geschützt wird meine damen und
herren oder im letzten punkt der mir
ganz wichtig ist weil wir natürlich nur
nicht nur schutz master machen sondern
mehr geben auch eine ganz klare
perspektive wir geben der
bundesregierung jetzt eine
rechtsverordnung ermächtigung um zu
regeln dass diejenigen die nicht mehr
infektiös sind die geimpft sind die
getestet sind die schon einmal eine
infektion durchlaufen haben dass die
wieder freiheitsrechte zurückbekommen
das ist richtig das ist auch
verfassungsrechtlich zwingend und
deswegen werden wir hier vorangehen dass
wir schnellstmöglich wieder zurück in
die normalität kommen und dazu bietet
dieses gesetz einen wichtigen beitrag
und deswegen bitte ich sie alle um
zustimmung an dieser stelle vielen dank
[Applaus]